welcome back prostate cancer is the
second most common cancer for men and
today intermouth and health who is
sponsoring this segment wants everyone
to be aware of the signs let's welcome
to the show dr warren fisher welcome to
the show thank you appreciate it
appreciate the offer start off first
what is prostate cancer prostate cancer
is a cancer that develops in the
prostate gland and the prostate gland is
a gland that's just below the male's
bladder
so what are the signs what are we
looking for
so common signs and symptoms of
decreased flow of urination
difficulty starting or stopping urinary
stream
having to urinate frequently at night
feeling though you can't entirely empty
the bladder back pain maybe pain with
ejaculation
maybe difficulties with erections
and also perhaps blood in the urine or
blood in the semen now is there a
certain age group that men should be
more concerned with or should we be
concerned of all ages about prostate
cancer
well generally
over 50 and when i say that i say over
50 because prostate cancer continues to
get more common with aging but in the
general population we screen
men who have no symptoms
screening are between the ages of 50 and
70. if african-american males we advise
starting screening at age 45 and if you
have two family members direct family
members that have had prostate cancer
screenings should start at age 40. okay
let's talk about the screening process
what does it involve
blood test uh blood testing is very
simple blood test blood test with or
without digital rectal exam in fact the
majority of men receiving screening
nowadays it's occurring without the
dreaded digital rectal exam okay so
blood testing is very simple to do
versus some of the other the procedures
that might take place indeed now if
someone's watching right now and you
mentioned some of the signs what's the
first thing they should do some of those
signs you mentioned like wait a second
i'm dealing with that issue what should
they do well i would advise that you
seek the care of a primary care
physician see your doctor uh and talk
about this and go through a shared
informed consent process to determine if
you need to be screened for prostate
cancer i think it's for i don't know
maybe for everyone with guys you go into
the doctor's office you have a certain
issue and you see the doctor for some
reason certain guys they kind of hold
back
you just it's your doctor you should be
completely honest with your doctor you
have any symptoms correct correct and
and these symptoms that i've described
above you may have many people out
listening to this right now that say
well i've got similar symptoms and it
may not be related to prostate cancer
it's maybe related to other health
issues that should be evaluated it could
be benign prostatic hyperplasia or
inflammation of the prostate gland or
other issues but i still say in order to
preserve function go see your primary
care doctor and get them evaluated
doctor we appreciate very important
thank you so much for joining us thank
you thanks to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring this segment for more
information visit
intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada